New York City.
The Big Apple.
It isn't the capital of the United States,
but it's still the country's beating heart.
It's wild, weird, and wonderful, and in order
to truly understand how it turned into the
metropolis it is today, you'll have to take
a look at one of the most influential figures
in the city's history.
It's a tale of corruption, fraud, bribery,
ostentatious wealth, a little bit of creative
legal interpretation, and a lot of sheer audacity
and willpower.
One of the most important figures of 19th
century New York was William Magear Tweed,
also known as "Boss" Tweed and the Tiger of
Tammany, for reasons that will soon become
clear.
On one hand, Tweed was responsible for building
some of the infrastructure that made it possible
for the city to grow.
He improved the water and sewer systems, built
city streets, and oversaw the construction
of major landmarks, like the Metropolitan
Museum of Art, Central Park, the Brooklyn
Bridge, and the American Museum of Natural
History.
On the other hand, he was one of the most
corrupt politicians ever to rise to power
in the US.
By the time he died in 1878, it was estimated
that he and his network of cronies had stolen
millions from the state — a sum that's estimated
to be as much as $3.5 billion in today's money.
How?
That's at the heart of our story today.
Title: Street-fighting firemen
Tweed was born on April 3, 1823, and according
to most accounts, he had an average childhood.
He had the basic sort of education typically
available to children growing up in Manhattan
at the time; he once completed a brief stint
as a chairmaker's apprentice.
Tweed’s life seemed to take a dramatic shift
when, as a teenager, he attached himself to
his local volunteer fire company.
Here's where a bit of a secondary history
lesson is needed to truly do the story justice.
The volunteer fire fighting companies of the
mid-19th century were nothing like the ones
of today.
As a fairly new idea, volunteer companies
and they were half-gang, half fraternity,
with only a small amount of effort reserved
for actual firefighting.
Companies inspired strong allegiances among
their members and were closely tied to the
local politics of their area.
It wasn't unusual to have more than one company
racing to put out a fire, only to get distracted
by the sight of a rival company and have the
entire thing dissolve into a massive street
brawl.
And even as a teen, Tweed had quite the reputation
as one of his company's best brawlers.
Tweed had attached himself to Engine Company
33, which was also known as Black Joke.
For an idea of just what sort of folks this
particular engine company attracted, let's
jump ahead a few decades for just a moment.
In 1863, New York was torn apart by a series
of draft riots that led to more than 100 deaths
and somewhere around $1.5 million in damages.
Leading the way were the men of the Black
Joke, angry that firefighters weren't exempt
from the draft that was sending able-bodied
men from across the city to fight in the Civil
War.
They started by burning the city's draft office,
and it kicked off a full-scale riot that descended
into race riots so bad that the fire company
retreated from the front lines and went to
defend their own neighborhood from the burning,
pillaging, and beatings.
That is the company Tweed joined as a teen,
where he first made a name for himself.
After establishing himself as a charismatic
yet street-smart figure in the neighborhood,
he kicked off his political campaign and secured
a position as alderman of the Seventh Ward.
(An alderman is a judicial official that oversaw
some minor civil and criminal cases, and worked
closely with the mayor.)
That was in 1852.
Tweed rose through the political ranks fast.
By 1853, he had a seat in the House of Representatives.
Life in Washington, DC didn't suit him, however,
and he headed back to the city after just
a single term.
He'd kept his finger firmly on the pulse of
the city's political scene, and in 1856, he
landed a position on the city's new board
of supervisors.
From there, he didn't look back.
TITLE: Taking over at Tammany Hall
Now, a little background about one of the
organizations that shaped New York City through
the 1800s.
Tammany Hall was founded in the 1780s, and
it was originally meant to be a fraternal
society where like-minded individuals could
get together, socialize, and talk about politics.
Their actions became increasingly political
as the decades went on, and by the 1840s,
they had firmly established themselves as
an arm of the Democratic party.
Even more importantly, they had developed
a deep connection with the city's ever-growing
population of immigrants -- particularly the
Irish.
Tammany Hall helped countless new arrivals
get jobs, set up lives, and even get achieve
US citizenship.
In turn, Tammany Hall got votes for the candidates
they put forward in elections across the city
and state.
It seemed to work out for everyone.
Tammany Hall always had the stink of corruption
about it.
As early as the 1850s, it was clear that those
who were capable of rising to power within
the organization were also the type to color
outside the lines.
Isaac Fowler was the Grand Sachem — in other
words, the boss — before Tweed stepped into
the position in 1868, and his term ended when
he was charged with embezzlement and fled
to Mexico.
In spite of the scandal, the political machine
that was Tammany Hall kept increasing their
influence over the city -- this time with
Boss Tweed at the helm.
Tweed spend most of the decade establishing
himself in the neighborhood, where he was
already known as a larger-than-life character
-- literally.
At a time when the average height for a man
was around 5-foot-6, Tweed towered over most
at an impressive height of about six feet.
He topped the scales at almost 300 pounds,
too, at a time when the average weight was
closer to 150.
Add in the 10-and-a-half carat diamond he
liked to wear all the time, and you had an
imposing figure, indeed.
It was easy for such a memorable man to be
the center of attention, and that was a significant
part of why Tweed was so successful.
He wasn't just a politician sitting up on
high, raking in the cash.
He was on the streets, shaking hands, handing
out cigars and whiskey, and -- perhaps most
importantly -- listening to his constituents.
Tweed was famous for remembering names and
faces, investing himself in the stories that
people had to tell, and ultimately, doing
them favors.
True, those favors often had another attached
in return, but as Tweed was climbing the political
ladder, he had an impressively modest reputation
for honesty.
TITLE: Tweed, immigration, and voter fraud
Many of the positions that Tweed and his associates
held were still elected positions, and that
brings the story around to another important
point: just how did Tweed’s squad manage
to get themselves elected so regularly?
A big part of their success was the fact that
the ever-growing population of Irish immigrants
saw them as an organization that truly cared
about their welfare.
Many had fled The Great Famine, a catastrophic
crop failure in Ireland that led to the deaths
of somewhere around a million people.
When starving families of survivors reached
New York, Tammany Hall welcomed them with
open arms.
They even helped them out with baskets of
food and coal for their fires.
But it wasn't all good will.
Tweed was notorious for a brazen scheme where
he would recruit a few dozen volunteers from
among their loyal followers, ply them with
alcohol, and register them in multiple polling
places.
Then, he would pay law enforcement officers
to escort them from one polling place to the
next, and to make sure they cast their votes.
One person would vote dozens of times, and
that all added up to votes for Tammany Hall.
None of this was a secret.
Tweed also paid the officers to arrest any
voting inspector that started to get suspicious.
The most flagrant instance of Tweed using
his clout and influence with immigrants to
get Tammany Hall allies more votes came in
1868.
That's the year that Tweed arranged to have
around 44,000 immigrants become naturalized
citizens in the weeks before a major election.
It didn't go unnoticed, either; when Tammany
Hall members were elected to offices at the
mayoral level, and all the way up to governor
of New York, the House of Representatives
put together a committee to determine the
extent of Tweed's interference with the elections.
Nothing came of it.
The so-called Tweed ring — only continued
to increase their power and influence.
The same year he was under investigation for
interfering with elections, Tweed was named
to the head of Tammany Hall and elected to
the New York Senate.
Those were just stepping stones, though.
While Tweed was serving as House Rep at the
federal level, he had made friends across
party lines.
That allowed him to pass a charter shifting
the responsibilities of local governance — particularly
those that concerned budget and oversight
— out of the hands of federally appointed
boards and into the control of locally appointed
authorities.
And that was the truly brilliant part.
Remember when we mentioned that Washington,
DC hadn't been to Tweed's liking, and he opted
to leave federal politics to head back to
New York City?
When he did, that very same city charter was
waiting for him, and it passed complete control
of the treasury into his direct authority.
He and his cronies now had absolute control
over what the treasury paid out, and they
took advantage of it in every way they could.
TITLE: The Tweed Courthouse
No building or enterprise illustrates the
extent of the Tweed Ring's corruption better
than the Old New York County Courthouse.
The building is a stunning display of 19th
century architecture and craftsmanship, and
it's also known as one of the most prominent
legacies of Tweed reign at Tammany Hall.
It also ended up being the most expensive
building ever built in the United States at
the time, costing even more than the US Capitol
Building, for the simple reason that Tweed
and his cronies were in charge of both issuing
the bills and paying them from the city's
coffers.
The Tweed Ring was unthinkably audacious when
it came to manipulating these construction
bills.
The original budget for the entire building
was $250,000, a hefty sum for the time.
To give an idea of just how much the courthouse
ended up costing, that original budget was
only enough to pay the bill for the purchase
of the courthouse's brooms.
Other items were just as costly.
Plumbing set the city back more than $1 million,
the thermometers ended up at a rather pricey
$7,500, and a set of three tables and four
chairs came to a grand total of $179,729.
And there were a lot more of these “chairs.”
For the amount of chair money that Tweed actually
billed the city for, they could have bought
around 315,000 of them — and that's somewhere
around 17 miles of chairs.
Carpets for the courthouse cost around $5
million, largely because there was enough
carpet ordered to cover City Hall Park three
times.
What did they do with all that carpet?
Nothing, because it was ordered from companies
that didn't exist.
Some companies did exist.
Before construction started, Tweed had conveniently
bought a quarry.
It was that quarry that was used to source
all the marble for the courthouse, and that
bill alone was higher than the entire cost
of building another courthouse in Brooklyn.
Not all of the money was going right into
Tweed's pockets, as he also made sure his
fellow officers at Tammany Hall were well
cared for.
The grand marshal at the time was Andrew J.
Garvey, and he earned the nickname "Prince
of Plasterers" after he ended up pocketing
around $3 million for the work he did on the
courthouse, and for subsequent repairs to
his original labor.
So, how much did it end up costing?
When the state legislature approved the build
for $250,000, that was the equivalent of around
$6 million in today's money.
When it was finally finished, the bill hit
$12 million.
Adjusted for inflation, that's about the equivalent
of $200 million today.
It's no wonder that people started catching
on.
TITLE: The power of editorial cartoons
While there were plenty of people willing
to look the other way when it came to Boss
Tweed's criminal ways, not everyone was so
willing to allow the Tweed Ring to keep running
riot across the city.
One of those determined to bring down the
corruption of Tammany Hall was Thomas Nast.
Nast was a German immigrant who settled in
New York City and discovered very early in
life that he had a natural artistic talent.
The timing was excellent; with the start of
the Civil War, Americans were growing increasingly
interested in what was going on in other parts
of the country and, specifically, in the war.
Newspapers were still the way many people
got their information, and Nast's drawings
of some of the most famous battles of the
war catapulted him to fame.
He was one of Abraham Lincoln's favorite propagandists,
and he took on the big issues of slavery,
war, and eventually, political corruption.
That was a bigger deal than you might realize,
because his illustrations reached an entire
group of people who otherwise wouldn't have
cared much for what was in the paper.
Those people were illiterate.
Nast was working at Harper's Weekly when Tweed
was running Tammany Hall.
His campaign to shine a spotlight directly
on the rampant political corruption that dominated
the institution started by his calling them
on voter fraud, and it only escalated from
there.
Early on, Nast — along with reporters at
the New York Times — struggled to get something
to stick to the Tweed Ring.
Despite the fact that everyone knew what was
going on, uncovering concrete evidence proved
difficult.
...Until 1871, that is..
While Tweed had gone above and beyond to keep
his constituents on his good side, Nast was
not so easily swayed.
It's also important to note that Nast’s
campaign wasn't out of any righteous indignation
or a determination to clean up the city, no
matter what the cost.
Nast was a rabid devotee of the Republican
Party, and as such, he staunchly opposed the
idea that the Irish working class immigrants
were anything but trouble.
Since Tweed was so closely allied with that
portion of New York City's population, he
clearly had to go.
And on July 18, 1871, Nast and his colleagues
at the Times were given a gift.
One of Tweed's associates was a man named
Jimmy O'Brien, and O'Brien believed he wasn't
being treated fairly, in the grand scheme
of things, so he did something that had to
have taken an insane amount of courage -- he
took duplicates of the city's ledgers, strolled
into the Times, and handed them to an editor
named Louis Jennings.
Then, he walked away.
The Times began running all the sordid details
of Tweed's operation, and that's when Nast
really swung into high gear.
Until this moment of reckoning, when they
were handed actual proof and concrete numbers,
his cartoons were mere personal attacks.
He couldn't prove anything aside from the
fact that he was wealthy, but making fun of
that had no real effect.
But when Nast started drawing cartoons showing
Tweed as a fallen emperor, as passing the
blame onto others, and as seeing himself as
too powerful to be contained by a prison,
it was illustrating a more abstract situation
in a way that everyone could understand.
And it was Boss Tweed himself who best summed
up the problem he now had: "I don't care a
straw for your newspaper articles.
My constituents don't know how to read, but
they can't help seeing them damned pictures."
It was all downhill from there.
TITLE: The fall
Things started happening fast after O'Brien
handed over proof of just what Tweed and his
cronies had done to the city.
Members of the Tweed Ring started to flee
the country ahead of the fallout they knew
was now inevitable, and Tweed himself was
arrested in October.
Surprisingly, he was released on bail and
allowed to run in a local election, and even
more surprisingly, he still won.
But the end was nigh, and the following few
years would be marred by a series of trials
appropriately held in the still-unfinished
Tweed Courthouse.
It wasn't until 1873 that Tweed was found
guilty of 204 of the 220 charges brought against
him.
He was sentenced to serve 12-year jail term
that was quickly reduced; he was also ordered
to pay a $12,750 fine.
Even at the same time Tweed lost his freedom,
Tammany Hall lost their boss.
But it wasn't the end for them.
They passed their leadership into the hands
of a man named John Kelly.
He made major strides in overhauling Tammany
Hall and its image, turning it into something
more in line with what anti-corruption campaigners
and reformers had in mind.
It didn't last long, though.
Voter fraud came back with the very next leader,
who took over in 1888.
By the beginning of the 20th century, there
was another group that had a vested interest
in Tammany Hall: the mob.
When it came time for the 1932 presidential
elections, the Tammany Hall delegates were
escorted to the Democratic National Convention
by the likes of Meyer Lansky, Lucky Luciano,
and Frank Costello.
Afterwards, Franklin Delano Roosevelt delivered
some major blows to the all-encompassing power
of Tammany Hall — in part, by restricting
immigration and limiting their core supporters.
Things were never quite the same, and after
a brief scramble for power in the 1950s, Tammany
Hall disappeared in the mid-1960s, its doors
closed and its properties sent to auction.
But now, back to Tweed as his story isn't
quite over yet.
It turned out that even his jail time wasn't
much of a punishment.
Tweed served his time in a private room in
Blackwell's Island, with a window looking
out over his domain.
When his year was up, he was brought up again
on civil charges.
Prosecutors were hoping to recover some of
the money that he had funneled out of the
city's coffers, and when he was unable to
make bail this time, he was confined to the
Ludlow Street Jail.
There is, of course, a "but".
Tweed's cell was a two-bedroom set of rooms
with a small library and his own personal
aide.
He talked the warden into letting him have
regular visitors; he was even allowed to head
out into Central Park for the occasional carriage
ride.
On December 4, 1875, he headed to his home
with an escort of two guards.
After telling them he was going to check on
his sick wife, he strolled out the front door,
crossed the Hudson River in a carriage, and
escaped to New Jersey, where he went on the
run under the alias "John Secor."
In the meantime, the courts had continued
without him and ruled that, yes, he did owe
the city $6 million dollars.
With nothing really left to lose, Tweed continued
life on the lam, hopping on a schooner and
sailing down the Atlantic coast.
He met up with a man who was going by the
name of William Hunt.
It's not entirely clear who Hunt was, but
we do know that the duo hopped a fishing boat
to Cuba.
They were immediately stopped for not having
the proper paperwork, but before the governments
could coordinate to arrest him, he jumped
on yet another boat bound for Spain.
Unfortunately for Tweed, the six-week crossing
gave authorities more than enough time to
send word to Spain that they had a fugitive
headed for their shores.
Spanish officials were waiting on the dock
for him when he got there.
There's one last little footnote to the story
that adds to the sheer outrageousness of the
tale -- the authorities weren't sure who they
were looking for, but they were able to identify
Tweed based on one of Nast's cartoons.
It was, appropriately, one that depicted him
in the striped outfit of a convict.
Hunt was released, but Tweed was shipped back
to the US.
Only 11 months after escaping, he was back
in his old Ludlow Street cell.
He was 100 pounds lighter with hair that had
gone completely white.
He was a broken man.
Tweed finally agreed to confess to everything
he'd done in exchange for his freedom, and
in 1877 he went before a special committee
and not only admitted just how much money
he'd stolen, but he also named names.
The list was long, and included anyone who
had ever taken bribes to look the other way
for those who had helped with his election
fraud, or those who had taken kickbacks on
his construction projects.
In the end, the governor and attorney general
thanked Tweed for his cooperation, withdrew
their promise to set him free, and sent him
back to Ludlow.
Two weeks later, on April 27, 1878, he died.
He was buried in Green-Wood Cemetery, and
he left New York City a place entirely different
from the one where he had been born.